zero all engine running this is where
the journey began
altitude a moon landing that inspired a
then five-year-old
jeff bezos to dare to dream it's no
surprise that the launch of the new
shepherd is planned for the 52nd
anniversary of the apollo 11 moon
landing so he definitely wants to tie
the legacy of his new company to the
sort of aura and the mystique of
the accomplishments of nasa during the
space race
i want to go on this flight because it's
a
thing i've wanted to do all my life it's
an adventure
it's a big deal for me i invited my
brother to come on this first flight
because we're closest friends i really
want you to come with me would you
are you serious i am oliver is this your
first look at joining the bezos brothers
aboard the new shepherd will be an
18 year old teenager oliver damon
replacing the original unidentified
winner
who paid 28 million dollars at auction
and has given up the seat because of
what is said to be
a scheduling conflict you're in zero
gravity for four minutes
also aboard the craft will be
octonagerian wally funk
i'm ready i've been trained she was one
of 13 women who trained as astronauts in
the mercury project in the 1960s
but were barred from going into space by
nasa's then discriminatory
gender policy she's a non-paying guest
of the amazon founder
i feel fantastic i am so so
surprised but i won't know more until
everything comes around release release
release the new shepard flight comes
shortly after that by another
billionaire
richard branson along with three
crewmates and two pilots aboard
spaceship two
the virgin galactic owner caught a
glimpse of earth
from more than 80 kilometers up and a
few minutes of weightlessness
before gliding safely back down
this billionaire space race has not come
without criticism
what about the climate impacts of their
business empires what about
uh income inequality and their
problematic wealth
there are real questions about whether
or not these rocket companies are that
shiny object meant to distract us from
the wider impacts of their business
empires
but above all these flights represent a
culmination of one of the most intense
processes of privatization
the world has ever seen while some
public funds are still involved
it is clear that private capital now
also
controls access to what was once the
sole domain
of nation states
al jazeera washington